um okay so speaking of you know
[__]
um Amber Rose was on Jessie Lee Peterson
now this clip is a couple years old but
I just I found it on YouTube and I
thought it was hilarious
um of Amber Rose doing a collab with
Jesse Lee divorce and then I started
dating after that and it's like well if
going out on a date with a guy makes me
a [__] then that's just what I'm gonna
be I don't think going out on a date
made you a [__] but having sex with
different men makes you made you a [__]
well what does it make you if you have
sex with different women a [__] maker
oh that's so iconic it's so iconic
because it's true and this idea that men
sleeping around and women sleeping
around is the same or has the same
effects
guys it's just not
it's just not true
um and I actually think it's so funny
because Amber Rose is like
honestly she just LED so much of this
feminist [__] she led the [__] walks
um and just a lot of the nonsense we saw
like five to ten years ago was led by
Amber Rose and and the thing I like
about Jesse Lee is he just breaks things
down simply
he doesn't go into too much explanation
it's like a [__] his [__] maker
um okay so you know speaking of you know
promiscuous women in the media Brittany
Renner um who was a guest on our show
about six to eight months ago gives
Charleston white a lap dance and throws
water on him during a podcast so when
Britney was here a couple of months ago
she expressed that she really regretted
a lot of the men that she slept with and
a lot of the decisions she made and
people that I shared my body with
when I think about my list
it's repulsive because they didn't
deserve it
but that was an outcome of me
discounting my worth and
it's disgusting
um
I hate even having that
spiritual tie in any type of way but
yeah I would absolutely change sexually
how I move around and not even
necessarily because of like the societal
outcome it's more so
and I just want to point out why why men
don't accept our apologies I just I just
kind of want to I and I like Britney
like she was she was nice on the show I
got no issues personally with her but
the the issue the trend that we see is
that women will have
um an apology tour or you know
basically say they regret all these
decisions but then return to the streets
later
um so why don't we pull up the clip of
her on Charleston White's podcast
you know moist is one thing but wet is
just another
it ain't it ain't it ain't what we
shooting for
me
you hear what Miss ma'am
no no
please come on man please
I need you to be kind and respectful to
my to my guests
go ahead
go ahead and get the pig poker out
wait a minute
I just did nothing for that
oh
man she's running this this Runner Miss
Renner all right
there's a lot of equipment in here
for Behavior
all right all right all right
Landon
the stream is now for just for for
[__] private pretty private
what what did you do to get water poured
on you I was just being myself player
okay
bam I didn't know but bless you
I called you nothing but ma'am and Miss
Brenner all right
[Music]
I left for it you know what's funny if a
guy if a girl was saying no no no no no
and a guy went on to a girl that would
be assault but we get so much privilege
as women
like imagine if a guy went in starts
twerking on a woman and like pours water
everywhere I just you know I just want a
point not that
I mean I don't think they're traumatized
by it I'm just being honest but like
I just want to point out the double
standard and how women can behave badly
and not really have any real consequence
till at some point her looks are gonna
go and this isn't gonna be cute anymore
it's real it's not gonna be cute
um it's it I mean it already isn't but
you know just imagine like an old lady
doing that you'd be like what but you
know and this is why guys you know men
today accept a lot but
there's just some stuff that you really
can't come back from and I don't know
how you're gonna have a loving
relationship when this is how you're
presenting yourself this is how you're
acting
and and the thing is Brittany like you
you have a son and a lot and and when he
gets to a certain age people are gonna
show him this stuff and I know at some
point there's you you can't undo the
Damage Done but it's like why do why do
we keep going and making it worse like
wearing provocative outfits acting like
this especially especially in public
because that doesn't just affect you it
affects your kid
so you know um again this is women we
are so addicted to attention that if we
don't get the validation and attention
from Men A lot of times we'll resort to
this stuff and that's why the social
media age has really messed us up so
much because we're so used to getting a
certain level of attention that it's
unprecedented in all of history women
have never gotten this much attention
even the most beautiful women that a lot
of times when it starts to go away we
just kind of start to go crazy we start
to go nuts and do bigger and bigger and
more and more [__] for attention and
that's just female nature to be honest
you know
um there's there's writings from
hundreds of years ago about men
complaining about this kind of stuff the
only difference is now it's just out of
control all right let me know what you
guys think in the comments let me know
if there's a story you want to cover
please guys women shouldn't vote get
your shirt the link will be in the
description like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time